[Music]  Laurin Bushnell's  next step revealed after announcing her  split from Ben Hagen be who you are  because that's the most beautiful that  you will ever be ever here it is the  bachelor alum is now modeling for San  diego-based clothing store Vandervoort  people style broke the news and also  learned that Lauren is leaving at Denver  to return to her home state of  California where she'll pursue work in  the fashion State she launched her own a  lifestyle blog last year I always knew I  wanted to do something a little more  creative  I love interior design I love fashion I  love makeup and I was like what can I do  that really encompasses all of those  things and then I also had a fan base  that wants to know everything I wear  makeup all the stuff special oil fans  and so I also wanted to share that with  them and it just seemed like it made the  most sense and honestly one day it just  kind of came to me and I was like I need  to start a blog